story in five words
[Applause]
story in five words revenge porn costs a
billion all right cats this is an
amazing story jury awarded a Texas woman
woman
1.2 billion dollars after her
ex-boyfriend shared intimate photos of
her online and in emails to her family
friends and co-workers as someone who's
I can't read this to cat I should always
read these questions first what do you
make of this this seems a bit
extravagant don't you think I mean
obviously Revenge porn's bad I would
like to have that paper after the show
I just want to add it to my file
you're gonna need a bigger envelope he
asks you to quit the question was
directed at buck I figured I hadn't gone
to you first yet so I changed it without
change so the last part what this was to
a buck the last line is as someone whose
naked body repulses people what are your
thoughts
that's what I realized I couldn't say
the question to you because because then
I would why would you say it's a buck
I did not write it he's not coming back
from Scotland
you know oh I just thought of a joke
that I'm not going to use all right cat
go ahead no I think this is great I mean
they said that this guy doesn't have
this kind of money or any money because
you know Shocker the guy that this is a
loser
but it's just you know he made her feel
like oh whenever they Google you they're
gonna sell this stuff they want people
to see but now whenever they Google this
guy they're gonna see that he's a creep
and a disgusting person and a bad guy
and that's what he deserves but you know
what it is this is my problem
this is my problem Scott I don't think
it's fair to use like a court a court
judgment as a warning to Future crime
because you're punishing that person
let's say it's buck
for stuff he hasn't done so you're
saying like where we we're punished you
have to pay 1.2 billion so these people
over here don't do it that you can't
that's not Justice no and I'd have to
assume myself because I have put so many
videos on myself online naked and nobody
has responded ever
I'm 60 years old please objectify me
please
watch me and nobody cares so I'm kind of
envious that people care enough right
although 1.2 billion she could make a
really nice movie and she should of
herself because she's young and she
wants that footage when she's older you
must photograph yourself naked all the
time because you're hot now but in 30
years right oh I mean it just depends
I'll get I'll start getting the
surgeries yeah
I think when I turn 70 I'm finally gonna
buy myself just giant cans right
and you could get surgery too but
because you could have that fixed
whatever's wrong with you naked I don't
know what it is it's easy to know about
you know when I've been doing Barry's
boot camp I live in Florida I'm working
on yeah yeah yeah I think he wants you
to go to that Scott
hey that was pretty good that's the joke
I thought of earlier Scotland yeah Tyrus
what was the subject again
no I know 1.2 billion
I think uh you send somebody something
that personal and for them to do that I
mean that's just that's that's beyond
the pale like delete it and move on man
and he didn't just put it on the
internet he sent it to her family yeah
you know and the stuff that he probably
talked her into begged her to do text
her every day please send me one please
send me one and she finally does it for
him and then they break up doesn't work
out and he sends it to his family so I
think uh it'll be nice that every time
he tries to go to do something like
apply for a credit card or get a bank
account or go to a job like oh no sir
you hold one point
oh you haven't even knocked off a
hundred thousand yet sir like it's going
to follow him the rest of his life
because unfortunately it's going to
follow her right like there's no
Christmas dinner will never be the same
yeah they've tried to make it I think it
might even be a criminal Statute in some
states no no well that this is this
would be this was a civil judgment right
yeah yeah it's a civil judge and I'm
saying it's a criminal statute where you
can actually get you know locked up for
it I believe in some places because
that's why you stopped the point
the point
I should have gotten the earlier flight
anyway
I didn't have a window seat available
we can make a happy face out of it
seriously we can fix that
I don't even know what the hell he's
talking about this is
for reals no but uh but I think when the
Judgment I will say this when the
judgment is that big I think it actually
sends uh it's meant to send a message
but he's not actually going to pay any
of this no he's just going to declare
bankruptcy so I think you have to find
other ways to punish scumbags for this
that's what I'm saying all right
we will move on now
coming up life lessons from the heart
make us seem super smart hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else